it's time for me to tell you and show
you how I have configured the 32 teams
heading into week 12 and you can say
whatever you want you can say it's crap
you can say it's good you can say
anything you'd like to say and I'm going
to unveil for you and anyone else you
know football talk.com the top ten going
into week 12 and number one for the
second week in a row the Baltimore
Ravens now last week the Ravens kind of
got there by default because the 49ers
lost and the Saints lost so the Ravens
kind of fell into that spot they only
beat the Bengals last week but after
trouncing the Texans they now have a
firm grip in my mind on number one
number two the Seahawks three the
Patriots for the 49ers five the Saints
six the Packers seven the Vikings all
seven unchanged from last week the
Chiefs up 1 to 8 the bills up 1 to 9 and
the Raiders up 3 to 10 what do you think
of that Peter well first of all I
absolutely love having the Raiders at 10
I might even put him at 9 in fact I
would put him at 9 in that case because
I think the Oakland Raiders it's
happening quick but a lot of times in
the NFL
it does happen quick so I would put I
put Oakland 9 and the Bills 10 now Mike
I want to show you something on the top
of your rankings right now that it's not
in arguable and your rankings I think
are good but right now I would still put
the Patriots too ahead of the Seahawks
because I am convinced right now in a
big game at a neutral field between
those two teams that the best single
unit of the offenses and defenses are
the new English the New England defense
and I think they would find a way to
neutralize Russell Wilson enough to hold
the Seahawks in the teens and in my
opinion the Patriots can score 20 points
on the COS so give me the Patriots
number two Seattle three San Francisco
for New Orleans five I like that I think
that's really good and I agree with all
of them I'm a little
if he once you start getting into the
bottom five I'm okay with the Packers
you know it's six but I would put the
Chiefs ahead of the Vikings because I
just trust the quarterback more and I
understand that the Vikings defense is a
lot better than Kansas City's but there
were times in Mexico City where I
watched Kansas City's defense and I said
they're making some progress under Steve
spagnolo so give me the Chiefs at seven
put the Vikings at eight put the Raiders
at nine and the bills at ten and I think
we're good now I'm curious about your
comparison between the Chiefs
quarterback and the Vikings quarterback
because I've been at the front of the
line historically criticizing Kirk
Cousins and I have no qualms about doing
it when you pay a guy 28 million a year
that's part of what goes along with it
if you're not living up to that standard
but he has been living up to that
standard he has quietly been spectacular
in recent weeks he doesn't have the
Patrick mahomes highlight-reel but you
know when you see the great Patrick
mahomes play what you don't see is the
two or three not great Patrick mahomes
plays for Cousins
his average his consistency his ability
I mean his passer rating has been off
the charts he's only got one
interception since week two and it was a
ball that bounced off the hands in the
face of Stefon Diggs popped up into the
air and was caught by an Eagles
defensive back cousins and look this
this conflicts with everything I've said
most of the year about cousins but I
don't think the gap right now between
Kirk Cousins and Patrick mahomes is as
broad as people would think it is maybe
not Mike but I need to see it in game
until I see it against Green Bay in a
huge moment against the Bears again you
know and again I am in no way I I have
watched and I agree that Kirk Cousins
deserves an incredible amount of credit
for being as good
he's been over the last month or so so
don't get me wrong all I'm saying is I
have seen Patrick real homes do it also
in crunch time so again I want to see
that I've gotta Kirk Cousins before I
put the crown on them we did see it that
Sunday night a week and a half ago
though in Dallas he had 71 point nine
percent completion percentage six point
nine yards per throw a hundred and
eleven point five passer rating his
passer rating for the season and like I
know it passer rating doesn't take into
account what you can do with your legs
it's just your your performance as a
pure thrower of the ball one hundred and
fourteen point eight for the season that
is phenomenal especially when you
consider you at fifty two point nine
against the Packers I mean look
everything about him the arrow is
pointing up I just know that in my head
I can't quite get around he's also a guy
who lost to the Chiefs without in the
homes and you know it's it's a story
that remains to be written you know the
the final chapters remain to be written
and who knows I don't know at the end of
the day whether this is gonna keep up
all I know is I want to see it happen in
December in January let's turn the page
now to the second ten of the week twelve
Power Rankings at number eleven up three
spots after winning on Sunday in Detroit
the Dallas Cowboys at six and four
Texans dropped four spots from eight to
twelve after getting trounced by the
Baltimore Ravens the Rams up two spots
to number thirteen after winning at home
by ten over the Bears Colts up four to
number fourteen they beat the Jaguars 33
to 13 on Sunday the Steelers dropped
four after losing 21 seven in a game
that that wasn't as close as the final
score would suggest Titans hold firm at
number 16 Eagles at 17 down five after
losing to the page that may have
punished them a little too much for that
but hey they they're big boys they can
deal with it Panthers down one to number
eighteen Browns up four to nineteen and
the Jaguars down one to number twenty I
look at that Eagles falling five and I
prob
regret it but when I look at the rest of
the teams Peter the six and four is in
the five and fives I don't know maybe I
should have put the Eagles at fifteen
ahead of the Steelers in the Titans but
otherwise I feel okay about the second
ten Mike I'm moving the Eagles up to
number 13 in this case and I'm moving
the Steelers down to 220 I'd move
everybody else up there I'd mash it up I
do a little sandwich in there the Eagles
I think and again injuries may prevent
them from playing well but right now the
pittsburgh steelers and especially look
I know this gonna sound weird I will not
be remotely surprised if the Bengals
beat them this weekend because you look
at what Pittsburgh is going to put on
the field
likely no juju Smith Shuster likely you
know and you know all the the injury
woes that they've had so to me I think
right now especially after what we saw
and how Mason Rudolph simply cannot make
a play III don't they're not a
middle-of-the-pack team if you had put
him at 23 I wouldn't have argued with
you
yeah I look and then I could have
marquise Pouncy assuming his three-game
suspension or at least one game of it is
upheld so the Steelers are and it's a
week ago Chris Sims and I getting ready
for the Thursday night game we're
talking about how the Steelers here they
are at five and four and their four
losses or to the Patriots the 49ers the
Seahawks and the Ravens for the best
teams in the sport and only one was a
blowout and we got very easy to make the
case for this Steelers juggernaut to
keep going they had been 5 and 1 and
they were so bad last Thursday now now
the vibe on the Steelers has completely
gone the other way let's unveil the
final 12 and I have one thing to say
that was going to be my grievance today
but I'll go ahead and men
that now but we had the Bears at 21
Chargers down 1 to 22 Falcons at 23 they
moved up four they've been great in
recent weeks
Broncos 24 Jets 25 lions 26 and then it
finishes Buccaneers Cardinals dolphins
Giants Washington Bengals nobody cares
about the guys at the bottom the charges
of the team I want to talk about and
what Peter in in one of the TV only
segments we did last hour
you mentioned the Philip Rivers
conundrum what will the Chargers do will
they give him one more year as they move
into their new stadium I think it's time
for the Chargers to accept the fact that
they're in Los Angeles there's so much
talk about whether or not the Chargers
may leave LA and I tend to think that
someone from the Rams likes putting that
out there because it keeps the Chargers
down at a time when people are having to
decide which team they want to by PSLs
and tickets for and if you think the
charges may leave why are you gonna buy
Chargers PSLs and season tickets but I
think the Chargers have a duty to start
behaving like an LA team you can't move
to LA and ignore the fact that you're in
LA the Rams have embraced that from the
get-go
last year going into the the regular
season all the moves they made all the
sizzle all you know you can have
substance and you need to have subs
you'd have a football team that is
competitive but you also need to be
willing to do things that excite your
fan base the Chargers have done nothing
deliberately to excite their fan base
and that's why Peter I think the time
has come for them to move on from Philip
Rivers and get a quarterback who will
excite their fan base whether it's Cam
Newton whether it's a rookie whether
they make a play for Tom Brady who's
gonna be a free agent after the season
I'm not sure that that's the guy you
want but if you want to create some
excitement for a year going into your
new stadium that's a way to do it I
don't know why the Chargers resisted I
don't know if it's just not on the radar
screen but folks you're in LA it's time
to start acting like you're in LA and
making your personnel moves with an eye
toward getting your fans excited about
the team
your thoughts Peter
Mike you know you said something in
there as just a little pre comma post
comma thing it wasn't even a full
sentence but you said something in there
that I have been thinking that it's just
a thought it's not anything to report
it's just an opinion it's sort of
talk-show fodder but Tom Brady has set
up his contract to expire after this
season so at the age of 42 he is going
to have for the first time in his career
the right to do what he wants as as a
quarterback in 2020 and so if that
happens let's say he he chooses he's
gonna have a lot of choices
maybe he'll retire and make his wife
very happy maybe he'll play another
three years I don't know you don't know
no one knows but I do think that when I
look at the very short list of teams for
Tom Brady in 2020 the Los Angeles
chargers are on that list because he
would provide everything that the
Chargers want number one a huge
attraction at the gate huge you know
it's like the Lakers and LeBron secondly
it would provide a newness a freshness
to this team that they just haven't had
in a long time but I will give you the
wet blanket part of all this and that is
that it is simply not a Tom telesco move
general manager of the Chargers he comes
from the Bill Polian School the
meat-and-potatoes school he doesn't mind
making a gutsy move here in there but to
put your team in the hands of a guy
who's gonna be 43 years old in 2020 I
think would be a little bit much for Tom
telesco but the only point I'm making is
that it's an interesting backdrop in
everything that the Chargers have going
right now at this point in their history
and look maybe it's time to depart from
the Bill Polian ways and recognize again
you're in LA telesco was hired at a time
the charters were in San Diego and there
wasn't an imminent relocation there
needs to be an imminent reconsideration
of the way they stock this team or
they're never going to compete with the
Rams and they're never going to resonate
in LA and they're just gonna sit around
and wonder why and they're gonna think
all we have to do is put a winning team
together and it'll change we know what
they were twelve and four last year and
it didn't make a difference they need
somebody it's gonna move the needle and
look at all the the jerseys Tom Brady
still sells whoever gets Tom Brady next
year whatever he does if he goes to a
new team that team may not win a lot of
games depending upon what else they have
they're gonna make a crapload of
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports